Playing at Hillsdale was probably the best
four years of my life.
It was team, family.
The atmosphere was just family.
Coach Dick Lowry came in, and that was his
first year.
That was his first recruiting class.
We won the GLIAC Championship in 1980, my
freshman year.
It got Hillsdale back on the map for football.
Coach preached family, and discipline, and
character.
The friends I have are like brothers.
The most impactful person besides my father
and my mom but from the college was Coach
McAvoy who was like a second father.
Two weeks into my freshman year, I came in.
I was out of shape.
I wanted to go home.
Coach Mac saw me walking back to
Simpson Dorm and said, "What are you doing?"
I said, "I'm going home.
I, I'm embarrassed.
I can't get my equipment."
I'll never forget it.
He said, "Just remember that the decision
you make today will impact you and your family
for the rest of your life."
He said, "You know, the coaches brought you
here because they had a belief in you.
You've got to find that inside yourself.
Believe that you can do it, and, and prove
them, prove them right."
One conversation from Coach Mac
changed my life.
Started three years, was elected to captain.
Being elected captain by your teammates was
a very humbling moment.
Made All-Conference, All-District, All-American.
To sign an NFL contract was a dream.
I wasn't fortunate enough to make the final
roster for Detroit or Pittsburgh, but I had
two years in camps and preseason.
I can always look back and say, "I tried and
I gave it all I had."
To me, that was good enough.
The other person that made a difference in
my life was Keith Otterbein, our current head
football coach.
Otter reached out to me and asked me what
my plans were.
I didn't really have any plans.
I was reeling from the loss of my brother,
Bob, and coached reached out to me and gave
me an opportunity to come up to Ferris
and become a coach.
I coached for four years as defensive line
coach.
I was a strength coordinator.
Otter reached out to me at the lowest times
of my life and saved me.
The thing I miss most about coaching is how
you can influence somebody's life.
I had an opportunity to coach at the youth
level, high school, college.
Probably the greatest thing I still get is
when I run into former players and I hear,
"Coach."
I love it.
Being elected into the Hillsdale College Athletic
Hall of Fame is unfathomable.
When I made All-American, I thought that was
it.
It doesn't get much better than that.
I've been out of school since 1984.
You see the people up ... I've been back to
a couple Hall of Fame inductions.
To be considered the best of the best that
have ever played at Hillsdale, it's an honor.
It's hard to put into words.